So next, we're going to extend this idea of finding a path from V₁ to V₂
to the idea of finding a shortest path from V₁ to all other nodes.
And one of the reasons we want to do that is to identify central node in a social network.
Nodes that are likely to have a lot of influence, or well-placed, or very well-connected,
and so we're going to look now at the question of given a node V₁, how central is it?
Now, it turns out there's lots of different ways that you can define what central means.
We're going to write now focus on a particular one
which is the average shortest path length to all the other nodes.
So to find this quantity, we're going to need to calculate
the shortest path length from V₁ to all the other nodes.
Now, based on the analysis we've done so far, finding the shortest path length
from some node V₁ to some other specific node V₂, takes time Θ(n+m), nodes plus edges.
So, following sort of a naive kind of algorithm design, well, this should work and it's not so terrible.
It's to say, well, if we want to know the shortest distance from V₁
to each of the other nodes in the graph, we can just repeat this process
once for each possible target node.
So, we find the shortest path from V₁ to V₂ and from V₁ to V₃ and V₁ to V₄ and V₁ to V₅
and we can get all these distances and then say average them to get this measure of centrality.
The running time for that approach is going to be big Θ of n, the number of nodes
times the time that it takes to do a shortest path search.
So, it's really n times n plus m which is (n²+nm).
Now, the superhero data that we're looking at the moment has only order of 6000 superhero nodes
and 6000² is, you know, a substantial number and we'll be nice to avoid this if we could.
So, here are some choices for you, one possibility is you can't, just deal with it.
and this is the fastest way to do it which is essentially to repeat
individual pair y searches until you've exhausted all the nodes.
Another possibility is well you can make it faster by just using a smaller graph.
Another choice would be while you're searching for V₁, when not sure what to search for,
just search for something that's not anywhere in the graph,
and last choice is, actually, you can speed things up by doing the search backwards.
Now, actually all these choices sound kind of weird, don't they?
But the right one is this third one here and the reason that this actually works,
is if you search using the algorithm that we've been looking at,
if you search from V₁ for something that's not in the graph at all,
what is going to do it's just going to keep searching and searching and searching and searching
and building shortest paths to all the nodes it encounters along the way
until it discovers that the node that it's looking for just isn't there.
At the end of that process, every single node in the graph will have a shortest path
from the--will be notated, annotated with the shortest path from V₁ to that node.
So, the running time here is just the time it takes to do a single search,
Θ(n+m) and then you get the answer for all the nodes in the graph.